today on the matt wall show democrat
governors are now telling people how
many of their own
family members they're allowed to have
in their own homes for thanksgiving and
in general somehow the covert
restrictions keep getting even more
onerous and unconstitutional
not less we're trending in the wrong
direction here also five headlines
including
the governor of florida ron desantis
drafting legislation that will offer
legal protections to people who shoot
rioters and looters in self-defense
should we start the ron desantis 2024
chance now and
in our daily cancellation i will cancel
the rock i'll explain what he has done
to incur my wrath
all of that and more but first a word
from our very good friends over at paint
your life you know
holidays are around the corner and um
it's really important when you go in
to christmas you want to make sure that
you have a gift that you're confident
in uh and a family portrait from from
paint your life you know that's you know
you know you're gonna nail it with that
well let's say you're giving that to
your
to your mother for christmas and all
your siblings are sitting around
you know giving the gifts and she's
opening them and you just know
you have the best gift out of anybody
and so that gives you peace of mind as
well
if you want a truly meaningful gift
you've got to try paintyourlife.com
you get a professional hand-painted
portrait created from any photo
at a truly affordable price you can send
a picture whether it's
of yourself uh maybe don't give a
portrait of yourself to someone as a
gift i don't know but
children family special place a
cherished pet whatever it is
or you can combine photos into one
portrait so they can you got to
customize it that way as well
with paint your life's compilation
portraits you can bring together family
members who never had a chance to meet
so that could be a very
special thing or you can create a
portrait of the whole family without the
need for everyone to be there for a
family photo
you can choose from a team of
world-class artists and work with them
until every detail is perfect i've done
this myself
and i can tell you that this that part
really the whole thing impressed me the
final product impressed me but i was
also impressed with how
sort of hands-on they were and they were
asking for my feedback the whole time
that i was giving it
and it just turned out fantastic and
we're very happy with it we got a
portrait of our children right in our
living room
uh great conversation piece at
paintyourlife.com there's no risk if you
don't love the final painting your money
is refunded guaranteed
and right now as a limited time offer
get 20 off your painting
that's 20 off and free shipping very
important so get to get this special
text the word matt
to sixty four thousand that's matt the
sixty four thousand text
matt matt the sixty four thousand paint
your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
well governor andrew cuomo this week
took a break from his book tour to do
his favorite thing which is
issue new coronavirus restrictions cuomo
who
always has the aura of a man deeply and
unjustifiably impressed with himself
announced a number of new or rehashed
rules ostensibly aimed at reducing the
spread of the virus
among them is a curfew instructing bars
and restaurants to close by 10 pm now we
should note that
curfews make a lot of sense in combating
covid because the virus has long been
known
to be nocturnal it emerges from its
layer
once darkness has set in begins to feast
on the flesh of the living
i'm sorry never mind i'm thinking of the
zombies from i am legend
curfews would make a lot of sense if
that was the crisis we confront
considering that the issue is a virus
i'm not sure how closing at 10 pm as
opposed to 9 p.m
or 11 p.m or 12 a.m or 1 30
is supposed to offer any protection now
curfews may be
arbitrary and relatively onerous
especially for bars but
they're nothing compared to the other
major restriction
that was announced the state of new york
will limit private gatherings
at personal residences to 10 people
now they're not the first to take this
step connecticut and california have
similar measures in place
ohio is threatening to do the same what
was once unthinkable
and would have seemed absurd to anyone
with the foresight to predict it
if anyone had the force to predict it
back when the government was still
telling fables about
15 days to slow the spread this has now
become
our dystopian reality agents of the
state have assumed the power
to tell you how many of your own family
members
you can have in your own home
there are so many problems with this
that it's hard to know
where to begin starting with less
important sort of logistical matters
like
how does it make sense to put a hard and
fast cap on the number of people allowed
in a category of building
as varied as personal residents
this means that the cap for a person who
lives in a stuffy 400 square
foot studio apartment with three windows
in the whole place
is the same as the cap for a person who
lives in a 5 000 square foot
5 bedroom well ventilated home
now the former couldn't safely fit 10
people even without a pandemic and the
latter could easily fit
multiples of 10 without much trouble
now you might argue that it's not
feasible to come up with a customized
scale of restrictions
based on the square footage and
ventilation in every particular home
i would respond that if a sensible
coherent and fair law
is not feasible then there should be no
law at all
well we can't figure out a way to do
this effectively and reasonably so
we'll just do it ineffectively and
unreasonably better than nothing
no it's not better than nothing it is
significantly worse than nothing
in fact and how would any of this be
enforced
will local sheriffs do random house
checks on thanksgiving
is uncle ned gonna get tossed out in the
cold by one of cuomo's henchmen
if he's the 11th person to show up to
dinner maybe law enforcement will
check to see how many cars are in your
driveway and more than four cars will
provide
reasonable suspicion that you invited
too many cousins over for dinner
and they'll break down your door start
hauling people away in cuffs
i mean really how is it going to be
enforced or will they not enforce it
if it's impossible to even imagine how a
certain law could be enforced
without committing farcically absurd
civil liberties violations
that's a good indication that the law
should not exist
and if the intention is to not enforce
it then the law should not be a law but
a suggestion
or a guideline which people can and
hopefully will
simply ignore but aside from these
questions of logistics and efficacy
there's another question that we have
apparently stopped asking
as if it's some sort of irrelevant
detail when really it's the most
important detail
and that question is this who says the
government has the authority to do this
in the first place where does cuomo or
the governor of connecticut or
california or anywhere else
derive the authority to tell citizens
how many family members they can have
in their own homes what gives him the
power
the right the answer of course is that
he derives the authority from his own
imagination
and though he has no moral or legal
authority
or right to do what he's doing what
gives him the power is the simple fact
that
he has it i'm doing this because i can
seems to be the legal argument from
these
despotic governors in fact i posed this
question on twitter
about you know where does he get the
power to do this a number of people
answered scoffingly that
well of course he has the right to do it
he's the governor
what they don't understand and i can
hardly blame them for not understanding
if they woke up from a coma in march and
have been observing how government works
only since then
is that governors though they have the
power to sign laws are also supposed to
be subject to them
we don't call him emperor cuomo or
sultan as much as he might like us to
he's a governor and a citizen just like
you and me
or at least that's how it's supposed to
work
of course the primary source of power
for petty dictators like cuomo
is the acquiescence and credulity of the
populations they govern
which brings me to my final point and i
want to be very clear about this
and phrase it in a way that will will be
sure to be understood
if you support the government telling
how many telling people how many of
their own family members they are
permitted to have
in their own homes you are a fool
and a bad american and a disgrace to
your ancestors who came here for freedom
and would be in despair if they knew
that their own progeny
would piss all over their sacrifices the
way that you are
and i am embarrassed to share a country
with a craven imbecile
such as yourself i hope that was clear
enough
there are a number of understandable
and acceptable answers to a government
official who tries to tell you how many
people you can have in your house
most of those answers would come in the
form of expletives that i cannot repeat
but all of them would come down to the
words no
and go to hell but if you respond by
saying
yes lord whatever you say my king then
you are simply as i said
very bad at being american and i wish
you weren't
american because people like you are
ripping this country to shreds and
ruining everything that once made it
great
and beautiful this is all especially the
case
now because these same states put their
lockdown rules on hold as recently as
five days ago so that democrats could
dance in the street
yet again the mayor of dc broke her own
travel restrictions
a couple days ago so that she could go
pop champagne with biden in delaware
and she defended it as essential travel
this is how it's gone all along
these mayors and governors impose
restrictions exempt themselves
and exempt anyone who gathers for
politically favorable reasons in their
minds
as they try to force you to cancel your
grandmother's thanksgiving invitation
they have and will continue to allow
mass rioting and protests
as long as the rioters and protesters
are democrats which by the way rioters
always are
how much of a credulous brain dead
simpleton
sheep do you have to be to still go
along with this
to still believe the justifications that
are given to still respect
the authority of the people passing
these rules
so it's time to wake up it's long past
time
but if this is finally your awakening
moment well
better late than never i guess
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
this is from the daily wire says
representative rashida talib rejected
calls from within her party to curb
progressive sloganeering such as defund
the police asserting that such calls
amounted to silencing her and her voters
um talib pushed back against the calls
to moderate in an interview with
politico on tuesday
moderates in the party have blamed poor
results in a number of close races
on extreme stances of many prominent
democrats like talib and alexandra casa
cortez
um and she says this is this is the
quote i wanted to get to she says
we are not interested this is talib
we're not interested in unity
that asks people to sacrifice their
freedom and their rights any longer
and if we truly want to unify our
country we have to really respect every
single voice we say that
we say that uh so willingly when we talk
about trump supporters but we don't say
that willingly for my
black and brown neighbors and from lgbtq
neighbors
or marginalized people okay she
she towards the end there of course
she's getting into nonsense but
um i agree actually with the first part
of what you said
we're not interested in unity that asks
people to sacrifice their freedom and
their rights
um i would also add to that
i'm speaking for myself i'm not
interested in that kind of unity either
i'm also not interested in unity that
requires people to sacrifice their
convictions
and their beliefs and their principles
and values
uh to include you know their religious
convictions because that's
that's the kind of unity the democrats
want that's the kind of unity that
rasheed talib wants
so yeah uh a unity
that requires people to give up these
essential aspects of themselves and of
being an american
that is not a unity that i want it's not
unity that she wants
it's just that the problem is you know
she considers
it it's we have a we also have a very
fundamental difference
and opinion on what a right and a
freedom actually is
so she believes for example that of
course parents have the
god-given we're not parents sorry
mothers specifically
have the god-given right to murder their
offspring
that's what she believes um
and that's another reason why there
can't be unity
because we we can't even agree on what a
right
is on what a freedom is
you put i say this all the time you put
100 americans into a room
and you do a poll and you ask them you
know what what are our most basic and
fundamental rights
you're not even going to get like a you
certainly will not get above a 50
agreement on that and that's why there
can't be unity
i mean we're not even i i don't feel
like i'm living in the same universe
as a person who thinks that a mother has
a god-given right to murder her
offspring
as opposed to a god-given mandate to
care for her offspring
i also don't feel like i'm in the
universe with uh the same universe with
someone who thinks that
you know a mother can also be a
biological male by the way
number two the undisputed queen of
cringe uh and also a horrible mayor and
bad person in general
lori lightfoot of chicago has put out
another propaganda video this one is a
we do a cringe challenge you know we do
cringe challenges sometimes
well tell me if you tell me if you can
actually manage to watch
this entire thing without averting your
eyes i'm guessing
you can't make it through the first
three seconds now i'll tell you the
first three seconds are by far the
toughest
for three seconds this is olympic level
cringe challenge
type of stuff but if you can make it
through the first three then it gets a
little bit easier
here it is
thank god science is back baby
and the earth is round
not flat washing your hands
does work social distancing
does matter and wearing a face covering
does help protect all of us
i do love science
[Music]
yeah that was difficult that was uh that
was tough i feel like we've been through
in our
an ordeal together watching that um but
we're stronger now
we have a bond because we've all been in
the trenches
having to watch that being exposed to
that
so i thank lori lightfoot for that if
nothing else but she says
science is back science is back
is it really you know i go back to the
issue of pregnant men is that part
if science is back are we still doing
that
number three joe biden tweeted this tell
me if you can decipher this because i'm
trying to make sense of it
uh this is a couple days ago he said
when i'm speaking to foreign leaders i'm
telling them
america is going to be back we're going
to be back in the game
i don't know what that means i have to
tell you i have no idea what the hell
that means
well like i hope he isn't actually
saying that to world leaders i really
hope i hope biden
isn't calling up the prime minister of
japan and saying hey listen
we're back in a game what you're what i
don't understand what you mean the game
we're back in it all right talk to you
later
now i'm actually being generous by
saying that this is just nonsense
you know this is nonsense from uh a
person with the in
in feeble to mind the other way to look
at it is that joe biden
and this is this unfortunately i think
is probably the reality here is that
joe biden when he says game what he
means is
american interventionism overseas that's
the game to him
because that is one game that we haven't
been in
as much under trump now we have been in
it but we haven't
been nearly as focused on that
quote-unquote game
under trump and that's a game i don't
want to go back to
i don't know about you mainly because
it's not a game
these are these are actual lives that
are being destroyed
and actual billions and trillions of
dollars that are being wasted
uh and real wars that are being fought
often for no reason so i don't consider
it a game
joe biden does and that this of course
is
is one thing that i mean look you go
back
to the bush administration and ending
foreign interventionism and the these uh
absurd attempts to spread democracy this
was like
the number one priority of the democrat
left this is the main thing they talked
about
probably their their their number one
goal
and donald trump has done more in that
vein
to that end than any present in the last
several decades at least and of course
he gets no credit
for it from them number four uh this is
again from the deli wire says republican
florida governor ron desantis has
reportedly drafted anti-mob legislation
that would expand the state's stand your
ground law to allow
armed citizens to defend themselves
against violent rioters and looters
says written after violent rioters
caused billions of dollars of damage to
america's cities over the summer
the proposal would expand the list of of
um of
florida's uh self-defense laws to
justify the use of force against rioters
who engage in looting or arson that
quote results in the interruption or
impairment
of a business operation
says the draft legislation puts
specifics behind desantis's pledge in
september to crack down on violent and
disorderly assemblies
other key elements of desantis's
proposal would enhance criminal
penalties for people involved in violent
or disorderly assemblies
make it a third degree felony to block
traffic during a protest
offer immunity to drivers who claim to
have unintentionally killed or injured
protesters who block traffic
and withhold state funds from local
governments that cut law enforcement
budgets
the draft obtained by the miami herald
has not yet been filed as an official
bill in the florida house or
senate um i mean this is
this is actually great and
the question we should be asking is all
the other republican governors
around the country why aren't you
drafting legislation just like this
this is what needs to happen people need
to be offered protect
finally for once we're gonna offer
protections
to the the actual victims of these
riots and um and these looters
so this this is great from ron desantis
and this is why
i look i people ask me
all the time um who who
who would i like to see in 2024 like the
republican party going forward
who would i like to see be the leader of
the republican party
uh is there anyone that i that i'm that
i'm looking at for the future 2024 as a
presidential
candidate the fact is i hate
99 of politicians and
i'm lukewarm and republican and democrat
i i spread the hate around so i'm very
you know i'm very tolerant in that way
um so i hate 99 of politicians
the other one percent i'm very lukewarm
on with with
a few a few exceptions and i would say
ron desantis is certainly one of the
very few exceptions
i would be yeah i say the chance for for
desantis 2024 should uh
should start now and he's done a
brilliant job in florida and this is the
kind of thing
that most republicans wouldn't have the
guts to get behind but he does
so ron desantis i think he joins the
list the very very small list of
republicans that
there's reason to be excited about
number five finally major controversy
stemming from an episode
a recent episode of the show the
mandalorian on disney plus
uh that's the star wars show by the way
because there were
you know there were a couple of decent
star wars movies 40 years ago which
means we have to keep having star wars
movies over and over forever
but this controversy is based on a
highly offensive scene involving baby
yoda
the new york post reports in the latest
episode of the mandalorian the character
dubbed baby yoda
caused a death star level commotion
among fans
when the little green sensation tried to
eat the eggs of a new alien character
baby yoda whose real name is the child
is so is he not really baby yoda
is baby yoda not actually yoda as a baby
i don't know i don't watch the show uh
he's tasked with
shuttling a character in her eggs to a
new planet before they die however
several times during the episode baby
yoda is caught either trying to steal or
eating one of the eggs
this attempt at a running gag drew the
ire of many fans who saw this as
vilifying baby yoda
uh one viewer said i'm a mom it's not
funny at all to hear
mama frog lady go into great detail
about how important and beloved her eggs
are to her
and have to watch them get eaten on
three separate occasions
just for giggles can't just one mom get
to survive
and keep her kids someone else says for
the record the frog lady was very
adamant about the fact that her eggs
were important to her
and that it was her last and only chance
to have kids so it's actually
closer to effing up someone's in vitro
fertilization which would be
incredibly upsetting for a wannabe mom
it's not funny
so this is an alien frog creature in a
star wars movie
eggs being eaten by baby yoda now i'm
i i'm pretty sure this is one of those
tried and true instances of the media
creating a quote-unquote controversy out
of a handful of tweets
from random people expressing a dumb
opinion about something
um but even so to the extent that people
are upset about this and maybe i'm just
being
optimistic and hopeful that this isn't a
real thing you know there's just like
just a couple
and the media does this all the time a
couple of people say something dumb on
twitter
and they turn it into a headline but
even so
to the extent that people are upset
about this i have to say that
it's sad that there would be any outrage
at all
over the death of a fictional alien
fetus
in a country where actual human children
are
legally murdered by the millions but
this is the thing
the fake frog lady in star wars and her
babies that's what we're worried about
great makes a lot of sense all right
we're going to get to our daily
cancellation just a second
uh before we do you know it's
i i think an important part of having uh
you know to
going out and being confident in your
outfit and what you're wearing is having
a good quality watch
vincero uh they've been with the show
for a long time vegero is dedicated to
the craft
and they put time and effort into
crafting timepieces so so that you can
wear them
day in and day out and they're gonna you
know it's high quality so they're not
gonna break they're not gonna get
damaged
after a year of wearing this watch you
know it still feels great to me
uh looks great i love wearing the
watches i've got i've got a bunch of
them in fact
and um trust me i talk about this brand
often because i believe in the products
they make you can head over to
venturawatches.com
walsh don't hesitate because right now
they have a site-wide sale up to 15
off anything on their site and this
sale's not going to last forever you
want to go at least go check it out and
see these watches i know you're going to
find one that you love
plus they make the perfect gift
especially with the holidays coming up
and you're thinking about what kind of
gifts you want to buy well here's one
with vincero there's no brand name
markup there's no big time
price tags their promise to you is very
simple it's solid
well-made products that you will enjoy
wearing you'll look great
wearing my listeners uh have been the
hero for vincero this year seriously
the guys at viceroy have told me that
they're extremely grateful for all of
your support
and uh i know i i get emails and
messages from people who've also gone to
vincero
and love it and you know the one thing i
like about vincero is that the watches
are affordable but not cheap
and there's definitely a difference
between those two things and anyone
who's
had a cheap watch knows the difference
these are affordable but they're very
well made watches
so continue to support this brand as
they continue to support the matt wall
show
that means going to venturawatches.com
forward slash walsh that's
v-i-n-c-e-r-o watches dot com forward
slash walsh to take advantage of this
sale opportunity
and get one of my go-to washes at such a
great price like i said these are
timepieces you will enjoy wearing
every single day if you don't ventural
will make it right so go to
vincerowatches.com
forward slash wash walsh walsh there we
go
walsh and watch a little difficult for
me anyway
um one other thing to note before we get
to our daily cancellation
you know if you've if you've been
disgusted by the legacy media
i'm sure you've already been disgusted
with them but if you weren't somehow
before i'm sure you are now
the media has preemptively of course
called the election in favor of joe
biden
and they're further further claiming
that trump is undermining elections by
not conceding even though
of course we we of course we know that
democrats spent the last four years
essentially not conceding by saying that
trump stole the election illegitimate
president so on and so forth
not only that the media has already
shifted from demonizing president trump
and his supporters to
flattering biden and harris before
they've even taken office they're
talking about i'm seeing all these
stories now about joe's dogs
give me a break uh jill biden and and
also the um what
what are you going to call him the
husband of kamela harris is going to be
what is he
the the second gentleman i think is so
there was a there's been a lot of
stories about that
the switching of gender roles isn't
isn't this very exciting
um well if you're sick of all of that
then replace your cable and your new
subscriptions with the daily wire we
have big plans for the next four years
and it starts today candace owens new
york times bestselling author founder of
the blexit foundation
is joining the daily wire we're all
excited about that she'll be launching a
brand new show
um early next year she's also going to
be writing for the site as well
we're going to be launching many other
things entertainment channel
investigative journalism uh
building partnerships with like-minded
creators prageru
by the end of the year we're gonna have
all the prager u videos on our site and
right now just to show you we're serious
we're offering 25
off all memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com
subscribe members get our articles ad
free access to all of our live shows
full three hours of ben shapiro show if
you come if you become an all access
member you also get to take part in our
all access uh discussions which by the
way i'll be doing one of those
later on today so remember 25 off all
memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com subscribe replace
the legacy media with daily wire
trust me you won't regret it okay now
time for our daily cancellation
okay today i'm canceling the rock dwayne
johnson he has canceled for various
high crimes and misdemeanors committed
in this instagram video which he posted
this week
uh from his weight room in case you guys
didn't know that the rock
likes to lift weights he made sure to
record the video in his weight room to
remind you
so here's what he had to say we have had
the biggest
voter turnout in the history
of the united states and you know that
is such a big deal because you know it
tells me number one we were unified on
that day and just in terms of
everybody coming together every
everybody uh coming out to vote
uh mailing in your ballots doing
everything you possibly can exercising
the democratic right to vote which was a
beautiful thing
but it also tells me that this is the
most engaged
our country has ever been in the history
again
of the united states so for the fact
that we can come together and be
disengaged um
and be unified on the day of voting now
we may of course we voted for different
people
but that's okay we still came out and we
voted uh i wanted to shoot this
yesterday
uh when the news broke but um
but i i got a little emotional uh
admittedly so i got a little emotional
uh yesterday
manly tears of course i may have cried a
tier or two or ten
uh but they were all very manly all my
tears have manly um
but the reason why i got emotional
yesterday was
was was because of what i felt my vote
represented
and i was talking to lauren my wife we
were talking about our two little baby
girls and
and that's exactly what my vote
represented my vote represented
my little daughters my vote represented
humanity my vote represented
decency uh it represented the values and
the principles
uh of which we we we teach our little
girls
and my vote also for me represented
the importance of just being a good
decent human being
okay so a lot of problems here first of
all um this stuff about how we should be
so proud and happy that all these people
voted
i've already made my opinion on that
known i i don't see anything especially
praiseworthy or laudable
or desirable about the simple act of
voting the fact that lots of people do
it is not something to be celebrated in
and of itself
and if they're voting for a literal
dementia patient then that's even more
reason to refrain from
giving a standing ovation then he says
we voted for decency
whatever that means i'm still waiting
for evidence of this
mythical decency from joe biden but none
of that is the point
the real problem is that the rock says
he cried manly
tears over the election results
no those tears were not manly the rock
the term manly tears is in almost all
cases a contradiction a non-sequitur
it's self-refuting
there are precisely six exceptions to
this rule six times when a man may cry
we've already gone over this i think a
couple times somehow the rock didn't get
the memo
so we'll go over it again here are the
acceptable opportunities for a man to
cry these are the only six number one
death of an immediate family member
pretty self-explanatory
it has to be immediate family member
number two you get your arm stuck in a
wood chipper
i'm gonna allow the shedding of eight to
nine manly tears in that circumstance
don't overdo it though
don't abuse the privilege don't milk it
okay number three
uh the piece of sporting equipment that
you bonded with while stuck on a desert
island for three years drifted away
while you tried to row a makeshift raft
to safety
for this i think tom hanks provides an
acceptable model he of course had a
full-on breakdown
sobbing screaming the whole enchilada
but it was okay because he had developed
a familial bond
with the volleyball in this case it
really falls under number one the death
of a family member
number four your firstborn son is
awarded the medal of honor or the
heisman
this is a time of tears of pride but
note where i stipulate firstborn it has
to be your firstborn
because if your second son gets it after
your firstborn son it's going to be old
news at that point
and you're gonna kind of be annoyed
you're gonna say hey get your own thing
live your own life all right
on the other hand if your second
achieves those honors but your first son
didn't your pride will be stained by the
bitter embarrassment of your oldest son
being such a disappointment by
comparison
i mean your younger son is a war hero
and your oldest son who you had such
high hopes for
is like working at chipotle this
disparity i think will ruin the moment
at least a little bit
number five you're trying to get out of
a speeding ticket this is controversial
i'm gonna allow tears here it's never
worked for me
i should warn you and i have tried but
whatever whatever you have to do if it
works it works
by any means necessary if you can cry
your way out of an irs audit
two then more power too i'll allow that
as well
six finally a a a brief moment of crying
will be allowed upon the completion of a
long and arduous journey to a long
sought destination so say if you're a
16th century explorer sailing to the new
world
a future astronaut reaching a new planet
or if you're me when i walk through
three terminals in atlanta to get to the
one restaurant the whole airport with
decent tacos
any of those scenarios or something
similar will constitute an appropriate
excuse to cry
however you will notice that your
favorite politician winning an election
is not on the list and i feel like i
should also mention that running out of
steroids
is also not on the list i'm not saying
that would be relevant to the rock i'm
just mentioning it for no reason
just throwing that in there so uh the
rock is canceled along with any men who
cry for
invalid reasons that's going to do it
for us today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
joe biden's covet advisor wants us all
to lock down for just
four to six weeks to revive america this
whole 241 days
after we were told 15 days to slow the
spread we're getting a recount in
georgia we're getting more ballots
being counted in arizona and america's
worst enemies around the world
are parroting democrat talking points
check it out on the michael knowles show